[Music]
hi everyone my name is Ria Clair Frasier
Spears I am an assistant professor at
the University of the Incarnate Word fik
School of Pharmacy in San Antonio Texas
um here I teach pharmacology to
third-year students in our program but I
also have research interest that are
involved in looking at um things that
regulate the activity of particular
types of Transporters so I'm excited to
be a part of the um speakers for webinar
that's talking improve models in drug
Discovery and preclinical development
emerging assays where I can talk to you
a little bit about the microplate reader
detection of a floresent substrate
called ASP plus and how we use it to
assess transport transporter activity
and and identify novel
Inhibitors here are the object
educational objectives so after you've
listened to this information you should
be able to define the fluorescent
molecule that we use the type of
transport proteins that we study and the
express expression system that was used
next you can identify three differences
between uh the traditional radian
binding methods first is this
fluorescent substrate micro microplate
detection technique and finally you may
be able to outline some of the steps of
how ASP plus can be used as a
preclinical tool to ass transporter
Inhibitors using the high throughput
microplate detection
format so first why are we interested in
drugs that Target octs um or organic
cation Transporters these are belong to
a family of high affinity excuse me high
capacity lity transporter of which
there's three subtypes oc1 oc2 and
oc3 that are um come from the SLC 622a
family of genes so the oc3 transporter
is produced from the slc22 A3
Gene um another one of interest to us is
the plasma membrane monoamine
transporter abbreviated Pat which is
encoded from the SLC 20 9 A4 Gene so
these by saying that these Transporters
have a high capacity but low Affinity it
means that they're able to transport um
large amounts of their substrates for
instance but have a weaker binding
affinity for um
molecules octs can regulate various
neurotransmitter levels um both in the
brain and in peripheral cells and so
they're widely expressed uh in the brain
and the periphery and they have um
different different actions both with
endogenous compounds as well as
exogenous compounds to either regulate
the therapeutic activity for medications
or perhaps the metabolism of certain
medications um so although these
proteins are widely expressed in the
body there's very few pharmacological
drugs that are available to selectively
selectively Target organic cat
Transporters um some that are wi and are
commercially available are denum 22 this
is a non-selective compound that
inhibits the um organic cation
Transporters and can also block Pat
corticosterone is a steroid hormone that
can has preference to inhibit oc3 and
norrine is another that we also use in
this study and it's a metabolite of
norepinephrine so despite there being
existing um chromologic available or
excuse me commercially available lians
for o um the the field could benefit
from having a larger library of
compounds that Target these proteins and
so um we're interested in developing
techniques as well as being able to
screen novel compounds that selectively
Target OCS and perhaps create a new
Avenue for improved
Therapeutics one example of how oct3 can
be targeted um was shown from previous
preclinical studies in the lab of Dr
Lynette Daws and here we show that with
use of the non-selective inhibitor of 's
denum 22 it's able to enhance the
effects of the selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitor fluvoxamine in that
with the presence of descending 22 and
fluvoxamine together you're able to see
increases in inhibition of immobility
which is a measurement of
anti-depressant like effects of the drug
combination in addition you also see
increases in the inhibition of Serotonin
clearance indicates that the combination
is able to increase the concentrations
of Serotonin measured in the brain again
these are preclinical models and it only
um provides one example of how oct3 uh
could potentially be targeted as a novel
therapeutic
agent so one way that the uh function of
organic cadam
Transporters is measured is using a
traditional transporter measurement
called trated MPP Plus in this diagram
it's showing you how um we can use
increasing amounts of trated MPP plus
and expose different cell populations um
to trated MPP plus and if we keep the uh
amount the initial amount of trated MPP
plus standard we could actually increase
concentrations of an unlabeled drug to
compete for that tritiated MPP plus and
so in the presence of increasing
unlabeled drug concentration shown in
the purple triangle you would see
reduced measurements of the trated MPP
plus and this is referred to as the
total uptake relative to that drug
concentration in these studies you would
also include non-specific uptake where
you can block the transport protein of
Interest so in our case oc3 would
Beed and um that would show A reduced
amount or non-specific uptake of trated
MPP plus and in the data that I'll show
you moving forward what we do is end up
subtracting these two values so the
total minus the non-specific uptake to
obtain a calculated specific uptake of
MPP
plus some of the earlier work that we
were interested in to try to find new
compounds that Target O3 began with
screening a small Library using this
tritiated PP plus method so chemist that
we collaborated with made derivatives of
desum 22 two of which are shown here on
the left is called compound two on the
right compound
seven and what we can show is by using
the tritiated MPP plus method in cells
that overexpress oc3 we see some
compounds don't show a difference
between their ability their ability of
this compound to inhibit MPP Plus in the
oct2 isopor or cells that Express oct3
versus cells that Express P whereas
other compounds like compound seven
shown on the right you are able to see
measurable differences between the
ability of um the compound compound
seven to inhibit treated MPP plus uptake
in these cell types where in this
particular experiment it show that um
the compound seven had a higher potency
for the O3 cell
type and so while this was interesting
and encouraging we were interested in
screening larger libraries and there's
some limitations to using the trated MPP
plus with uh large screens you compare
the chinel radian essay versus um what
I'll talk about moving forward the
microplate technique the radian binding
Essay with chemicals like trated MPP
plus are typically more expensive
expensive because the radien itself or
the um
trated compound is more is expensive and
these can be um chemicals that are the
isotope is linked to either an inhibitor
or a substrate so MPP plus is a common
um radio labeled
substrate in addition the
instrumentation that's used to measure
tritiated MPP plus is also uh can be
expensive um while you can do
sort of high throughput screening
formats using a superfusion automated
system you also would need to have a
similation counter in order to count the
uh radioactive isotope measurements and
those instruments can also be
expensive the measurement speed in
comparison is also slow so it takes um
to the order of hours and sometimes days
to read all of the counts and working
with radio labor compounds Al often
require require training as well as
designated workstations and can increase
the risk for contamination and also
hazard waste
disposal compared to that the ASP plus
fluorescent uptake assay is much more
affordable in that the commercially
available ASP plus which stands for 44
diethyl Amino sterile one methyl
peridium iodide and a structure is shown
there on the right um is commercially
available and significantly cheaper than
radio labeled chemicals the
instrumentation we use the microplate
reader um can be standard in most labs
and is less expensive in compared to the
superfusion or culation counters that
would be needed for radio Lian
binding then the measurement speed is
much more uh is much more rapid where
you can get signals um in the order of
minutes as compared to hours or days and
minimal training is required especially
um or specialized equipment there's
fewer contam mination risk as well as
generation of hazardous waste so this is
very um attractive to me and my research
studies especially with the environment
that I work in um where a lot of our
work is carried at by students and so
the ASP plus method offers a a easier
Avenue to train students in academic
research and so we were then interested
in taking this ASP plus essay and
developing it into a high throughput
format in order to conduct larger drug
screens so this work was initiated by my
mentor and collaborator lyette dos at
the health science center here in San
Antonio through a small pilot Grant
funded by the National Institute of drug
abuse in collaboration with drors Blau
and Decker at the research
institute um where I also contributed
some uh information to this study and so
the aims um the three aims of this grant
were first to screen an existing library
of compounds around 1500 compounds for
their effects to inhibit
ot3 um we started with the Tre MPP plus
method and quickly realized we needed to
move to the ASP plus format other aims
for the grant were to assess lead hits
for their activity at other isot forms
of ooc as well as Pat in order to um
hopefully identify selective compounds
for O3 and lastly characterize the
ability of those lead O3 selective
compounds to inhibit dopamine uptake in
the
brain on the right I'm showing
representative data from our initial
assay using tritiated MPP plus which
really helped us verify that ASP plus
can be as a sub of O3 in our hands and
we use that traditional trated MPP plus
uptake model that I um described earlier
where we expose cells to a standard
amount of trated MPP plus and compete
that with increasing concentrations of
unlabeled ASP Plus in this case and we
could show that there's um an expecting
decrease in the trated MP plus MPP plus
signal as you add higher concentrations
of ASP
plus so next we ended up um performing
steps to optim imiz the ASP plus
microplate method it's again we were
interested in uh screening larger
libraries of compounds so we did the
work to optimize the buffer system and
we used a KBS ringer hippes assay buffer
that's pH to
7.4 our cell types that we use are um
embryonic kidney cells that overexpress
the human O3 as our initial
model for the plate types we begin in um
black sided clear bottom 24 four well
plates but then shifted to the 96 well
plates um and these plates were coated
with polyene to assist with cell
adherence we optimized the cell density
so at the 96 well format we seed the
cells at 50,000 cells per well they're
incubated for about 24 hours and the
assay is conducted at 37 degrees over 10
minutes after that time the a ASP plus
uptake assay is ended with some wash
steps in cold buffer and then the cells
are liced to release the amount of ASP
plus within the
cell um we use a multimode microplate
reader um where there's a excitation
setting of 800
485 uh plus orus 35 nanometers and an
emission signal of 590 plus or minus 25
nanometers in order to read the relative
fluorescent present from the ASP plus
within each sample
as far as the experimental designs we
needed to do um use this method to
verify uptake saturation of ASP plus so
here we used concentrations of ASP plus
ranging from 0 to 100 micromolar in
order to determine the KD for ASP Plus
in our
setup next we did uh primary and
confirmatory
screens where compound pounds were um
looked at for their ability to inhibit
ASP plus uptake either at 10 micromolar
or one micromolar of the
compound we have initial competition
assays where a standard concentration of
ASP Plus at the KD was competed with
increasing concentrations of Novel
compounds ranging from 0 to 10
micromolar in order to determine the
inhibitory concentration for 50% of the
response um generated by those compounds
finally for the selectivity assays we
measure the competion of ASP plus uptake
from lead compounds in different o
subtypes so with all of these type of
measurements you need to obtain the
total uptake which is um the measurement
of the relative fluorescence units of
with a ASP plus present you also have
samples that contain um that are used to
determine non-specific binding and this
is measured measured uh in the presence
of a Blocker of the O3 transporter which
you may remember could be corticosterone
so here we used 100 Mo micromolar
corticosterone and then those two
measures can be subtracted to obtain the
specific uptake which you can either
show as U the raw relative fluorescent
units or as a percent of the maximum
binding in that case the calculation is
the um specific uptake so again that
total minus non-specific bind
um taken as a divided by the maximum
uptake with the ASP plus alone and
multiplied by 100 this data is then um
analyzed in graphpad prism software
where you can fit the data to a
nonlinear WR
analysis and so first starting with our
um very first experiments using the 24
well format after we established that
ASP Plus um is a substrate of the oc3
transporter um here we're showing the
ASP plus uptake as the mean relative
fluorescence units over the
concentration at different
concentrations of ASP plus measured up
to 100 micromolar and so we are able to
see that in the black line that you are
able to measure total uptake that can be
inhibited when you have a um when the
ot3 Transporters are blocked with
non-specific binding which is shown in
red and when you subtract those two
values you obtain the specific uptake
shown in blue as another control in
addition to the non-specific uptake you
could also measure ASP Plus in Vector
transfected cells in which the O3 is not
overexpressed and there you expect of
course to see um reduced uptake of ASP
plus and so while this was promising you
can also notice that the mean FL
relative fluoresence units were
relatively low
and so it was um then necessary to shift
to the 96 well
format where um miniaturising the assay
can actually help improve our readout
due to the lower surface area of the 96
will
plate and so in this format on the left
we initially established saturation
binding of ASP Plus in the O3 expressing
cells by measuring the total uptake
here shown in the red line uh in the
left
graph also in the presence of
non-specific binding shown in the green
line and when you subtract those two
values you can obtain specific binding
of ASP plus over increasing
concentrations up to 100
micromolar on the right hand side we're
showing um confirming rather that we can
compete ASP plus uptake with known
inhibitors of O3 so here increasing
concentrations of corticosterone shown
in red or norrine that norrine
metabolite um is shown in
green and measuring their ability to
inhibit ASP plus over increasing
concentrations so here this data is
shown um plotted as the maximum binding
on the y- AIS over the um range of
competing compound in the x-axis
plotted on a log scale and this is how
we're able to show the um competition or
inhibition of the uh ASP plus uptake and
so here we show nice competition curve
showing that um both corticosterone and
nor medrine can potently inhibit ASP
plus mediated uptake through O3 where
the ic50s obtained or about 1.5
micromolar for
corticosterone and about 14 micromolar
for Norman and nephrine which is
consistent with the literature so these
were nice studies to verify that ASP
plus uptake can work well for us in this
96 well
format so next we were interested in
conducting our primary screen of the um
novel compounds to determine whether or
not any of those compounds um could
Target oc3 so this primary screen
involved about 1,500 compounds um at a
concentration of 10 micromolar that were
measured across four plates um measuring
four plates per day over five days to
give about 20 plates um it's important
to note that initial parameters were
also assessed during this primary
screen which included the Z Factor um
which assesses how the uh assay is able
to produce a robust signal um that can
produce a statistical effective size
um also the SB or the signal to
background ratio um which is taken as a
mean of the signal and the mean to the
background and having that as greater
than four is uh good for high throughput
screening and then finally the percent
coefficient of variation um having that
set to than or equal to
10% um that there's low variant between
the samples on the plate um and so I
showing this data here but um in summary
the data over the 20 plates were within
limits for each of these parameters to
show that the ASP plus method is a good
high throughput screening
tool so from those nearly
1,500 compounds um we obtained a hit
rate of 7% where 105
compounds had a maximum binding um
Affinity of less than 75% compared to
Norman and ephrine so in the graph on
the left
we're showing the total binding for
these compounds in
red their non-specific binding in green
so when ASP plus is measured in uh the
presence of 100 micromar
corticosterone um that's the
non-specific binding that's obtained
where you see a large reduction um
that's expected for the relative
fluorescence units same for nor
metrine and then are compounds in purple
where there's very ation between um
compounds that are able to uh produce a
rfu or relative fluoresence units and
some that are able to inhibit that ASP
plus induced relative
fluoresence in our confirmatory screen
um those initial 105 compounds that were
identified from the primary screen were
then tested at two concentrations 10
micromolar and one
micromolar in the same essay where we're
showing um
their the relative fluorescent units of
their ASP plus um in the presence of
either total
binding the non-specific binding with
corticosterone with normen andrine or
with the two concentrations of the
conator screens for the compounds 10
micromolar in purple or one micromolar
in Brown
this showed that 27 compounds then had
confirmed activity to inhibit ASP plus
uptake um with a hit rate of
1.8% in the final essay uh we took the
27 compounds and are starting to do
initial competition assays to determine
the ic50s of those compounds because
remember the confirmatory screen used
those uh novel compounds that only two
concentrations and so here I'm just
showing um five representative compounds
from that 27 compound screen and we can
nicely see that some of them are able to
potently inhibit the ASP plus uptake so
again when you have increasing
concentrations The Compound on the
x-axis and plot that as a percent of the
maximum binding you see that uh certain
compound comp A and B are have a potent
leftward shift in the ability of their
those to inhibit the ASP plus binding
and others are less potent or have a um
rightward shift in their dose response
or concentration response
curves now the use of ASP plus uh goes
back historically and there's many many
studies um in the primary L primary
literature that show uh ASP use in
either radi binding in microscopy
studies and also in microplate studies
and more recently um the ASP plus
microplate technique has been used to
assess transporter function and try to
identify um interactions of O
Transporters with various drug
medications hopefully our studies will
uh be able to add information um to this
growing body of work showing that ASP
plus microplate method is indeed
feasible it's versatile and an
affordable way that can rap be rapidly
used to assess transporter function and
identify new compound
interactions the ongoing experiments for
the study that I showed you today um
include conducting the
competition with the uh those 27 Al
compounds in order to identify the ones
with the lowest ic50 values to inhibit
oc3
our data are encouraging so far being
able to identify Inhibitors that have
that can work in the nanomolar ranges in
addition we're continuing to evaluate
the selectivity of those hit compounds
at other ooc subtypes so we'll
transition to also measuring the ability
of these compounds to inhibit ASP plus
uptake in cells that Express o1 versus
oc2 and
Pat and lastly we also plan to use the
asp method and adapt it to other
functions or excuse me to other studies
where we're looking at the uh function
of OC that's expressed in different cell
types or tissue preparations again
adding to the um versatility for the ASP
plus microplate
method so with that I hope you're able
to now come back to our objectives and
understand the um how we're able to
define the fluorescent molecule that's
us used here which is ASP plus um the
types of transport proteins are the
organic cation transporter proteins and
our study initially focuses on
oc3 um and we use the human embryonic
kidney cell expression system there's
several differences between radi binding
and as uptake mainly that it's more
affordable and you can produce rapid
results with the ASP plus
uptake um and outlining how ASP plus can
be used as a preclinical tool again
that's also widespread and we're using
it uh to screen novel compounds for
their ability to potentially inhibit O3
in a selective manner in order to reduce
the ASP plus uptake and we could use
this in a 96 will format making it high
throughput and measure it through the
micr plate detection
method here are some references to get
you started if you to learn more
information about the importance of
organic C Transporters or the use of ASP
Plus in either um in different
experimental formats including the micr
plate
method and I'd also like to acknowledge
the lab Roots organization and um this
platform for the sixth annual drug
Discovery and development webinar series
especially the organizing committee
members as well as managers that uh I
worked with in this process Dr shaali
Bala Christina Todd and Lyn Brainard our
research collaborators and M for the
projects were Dr Lynette dos Dr Bruce
Blau and Dr an Decker as well as uh our
scientific technician here at UIW
Cynthia Franklin I'd also like to
acknowledge the Australian nuclear
Science and Technology organization um
for their collaborative work in that
very initial experiment where we looked
at um a small library of compounds using
tri8 and PP plus the funding for the ASP
Plus work was provided by the National
Institute on drug abuse with with a u8
grant awarded to Dr Daws as well as
internal research grants um funded to
myself by the F fik School of
Pharmacy thank you for your
attention